♪ Look around, everywhere
you turn is heartache ♪
♪ It's everywhere that you go ♪
♪ You try everything you can to escape ♪
♪ The pain of life that you know ♪
♪ When all else fails and you long to be ♪
♪ Something better than you are today ♪
♪ I know a place where you can get away ♪
♪ It's called a dance floor ♪
♪ And here's what it's for, so ♪
♪ Come on, vogue ♪
♪ Let your body groove to the music ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Come on, vogue ♪
♪ Let your body go with the flow ♪
♪ You know you can do it ♪
♪ Beauty's where you find it ♪
♪ Not just where you bump and grind it ♪
♪ Soul is in the musical, oh ♪
♪ That's where I feel so beautiful ♪
♪ Magical, life's a ball ♪
♪ So get up on the dance floor ♪
♪ Vogue ♪
♪ Let your body move to the music ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Ooh, you've got to just ♪
♪ Let your body go with the flow ♪
♪ Vogue ♪
(applause and cheering)